I'm Robin notch in case yeah Matt me
before if you haven't you'd like to make
me come say hello those of you who've
met me before probably don't want to say
hello so it's very nice to be here on
I'm actually at a different school now
I've moved from cranbrook I'm napping
and a more senior position and it's sort
of taking me away from Matt's a bit I
still teach one maths class but I'm
looking after and the whole pastoral
welfare of the school the well-being
framework and just as a quick warm-up
activity while we work for a few people
to come in the room and so you go into a
shop and there's a twenty-five percent
discount on all mark prices special sale
but there's also a 15th cent sales tax
and what would you rather when you buy
something would you rather they do the
discount first all the sales tax would
you like them to do the discount input
sales tax on or is it better if they do
the sales tax and then okay well we'll
have a vote and obviously immense
teachers but ends up you reckon in
probably sales tax first ok how many
reckon that the discount should be
applied first care how many don't think
it makes any difference where and how
many didn't put that how many didn't put
the hand up because there's a good
reason because you've got a broken hand
or oh
thank you now that's really interesting
because you messed teachers but I quite
often do that with my students and of
course the way we teach percentage and
sometimes is a little bit formulaic we
get them to do something over 100 and a
bit on and take it off and all that but
really what you're doing when you're
taking over twenty-five percent is
you're multiplying by point 75 because
you're finding 75% so whatever number
times point 75 when you put in sales tax
on you're adding 50 cent what you're
doing is the operation multiplying by
1.15 so basically what you're doing
you're either multiplying by a number
point 75 and then multiplying by another
number 1.15 or you're doing that the
other way around and of course the
commutative property of multiplication
is that it doesn't make any difference
which way around you do what's nice
about that i mean i was actually quite
surprised that only this lady at the
front was prepared to put her hand up
saying it doesn't make any difference it
doesn't make any difference and in fact
if you multiply points75 by 1.15 you get
the equivalent discount which is either
it's not what would most people think it
would be twenty-five percent off fifteen
percent on yeah most people say it's the
equivalent of a 10-percent discount but
it's actually not it's like thirteen
point something oh and so you can just
work it out by multiplying those two
numbers together and that will give you
the equivalent discount but you see
that's that's also you know this is sort
of year seven level really or you're a
or nine possibly and I don't mean that
patronizing me I mean that from the
point of view of actually enriching the
understanding of percentage and proof
because what I just did was a proof
without writing anything down I probably
would write it down with with students
and anyway so that was a bit of a warm
an exercise the point of this whole
presentation really is to engage with
students and maths class room which is a
combination of
kind of entertainment hopefully and sort
of ideas for really kind of getting them
confused and anyway without more of you
oh that was supposed to be too happening
the whole time okay so a few max jexster
stuff I think and I don't know whether
you've seen these kind of things on the
internet but quite good you can't see
that I'm confused as to why no cake in
the oven and room 20 degrees and that
one should be self-explanatory and
there's no one which I like to tell Ted
mathematicians which is how many
mathematicians is it take to change a
light bulb point nine recurring if you
don't get that mask friend and now I
like to vary things in the classroom I
think the part of actually kind of
remaining fresh and keeping students
motivating engaged is about reinventing
and creating teaching is a very creative
pursuit and that can be too here's an
example I had a the only class I teach
actually be a year 11 standard level
class there are lovely kids lovely kids
they work really hard there listen
really attentively they're very engaged
but the moment I asked them to do any
work I just chat away and its really I
don't see any passion say this is what I
did with them and i'm not saying session
today
is there a super fan to be history as
you of one experiment isn't it something
that I believe you guys went in the
men's culture it's about changing your
expectation okay so that you were French
cost refreshments in same as you
physical challenges head-on stations for
you for which are physical to which
amends so the dairyman's will be doing
physical physical physical physical
stations and then
hi in the
x
Oh
ok
so that was I I don't think that's
something I'll do every term or every
year and the super samide I did it but
really was to troll engage with the meta
cognition of what was going on in the
classroom and getting to think about
I've seen virtually every single one of
these students playing rugby or playing
netball or in some other capacity and
I've seen how hard how focused how
passionate they are and I just don't get
why that doesn't translate to the next
pass room so I thought it'd be a really
good idea to actually talk about that
specific leaves just one period first
half of a double period then I got them
to actually do a little bit of feedback
and then we got on with some meds so it
wasn't that this was going to improve
their mats dramatically but it was
interesting to see what they actually
said and I gave an analogy as well that
it's a little bit like when you're doing
that it's not this important to finish
the exercise off it's just important
that the quality of the work and what
you're doing in that session is really
kind of high quality and focus and a
little bit like I can remember when I
had a personal trainer to the first time
and he said you know I had to do 3 times
10 reps and on the 8th rep of the third
set I couldn't go on and I sort of felt
that as a failure and then he explained
no that's exactly what we're trying to
do we try to actually exhaust the muscle
and we've succeeded that the point in
having that three times ten reps is a
goal it doesn't mean that if you don't
achieve it you've failed in what you're
trying to do so it's the same thing with
maths same thing with doing exercises in
class um these were the worksheets that
I gave out to see if you're interested
to know what do we do and the first
standard it is just sine and cosine rule
drill questions and also the other
station which was math station was the
Australian maths
questions Oh today's some of the
feedback and I particularly like the
second one this one by having the
physical aspect honestly I was too tired
to add my math or be fidgety during the
maths I therefore found it effective in
obtaining focus but there were you know
there were some others saying I I
thought I could not think well enough
even though I was focused but it wasn't
the point wasn't that by doing the
physical exercise their mats would
improve it was really just to be
thinking about their engagement